تعود قضيه شركه الاستشارات الامريكيه
مكنزي الى الواجهه مجددا في فرنسا مع فتح
المدعي العام المالي تحقيقين بشان تمويل
الحملتين الانتخابيتين للرئيس ايمانويل
ماكرون رد الرئيس جاء سريعا وواثقا
فالتحقيق لا يدور حول شخصه بالدرجه الاولى
وانما على تهرب ضريبي قامت به الشركه خلال
حملتيه الانتخابيتين جيبغيكم
ومسؤولين ومنتخبين
اجراءات القانونيه في هذه القضيه من
الطبيعي ينتقم العداله بعملها وهي تقوم
بذلك بحريه
عام 2017
وتم توثيقها وفقا للوصول القانونيه
تابعات على شعبيته
ريتيموسيون المجوس اذا تبين وجود خداع
سيكون ذلك مكلفا سياسيا للرئيس لكن هذه
القضايا تاخذ وقت طويلا لان العداله بحاجه
الى دليل وبرد النظر ستشهد هذه القضيه
وردا
الشريكه تضحك هذه الاتهامات بالقول انها
دفعت ما يقرب من نصف مليار يورو خلال
السنوات القليله الماضيه ثقه ماكرون بعدم
تورطهم عام كنزي يقابلها اصرار على تورطه
من قبل معارضه في اقصى اليمين هؤلاء
يستبشرون خيرا بان احد القضاه الثلاثه في
هذه القضيه نجح باذنه رئيس الوزراء الاسبق
فرانسليون ما ادى الى انسحابه من سباق
الرئاسي الذي فاز فيه مكروه عام 2017 فادي
دهوك العربيه باريس